hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to punishment the punishing now
with a name like that there can be no
mistake this is a rage game and it has
been a while since I have played these
types of games so I thought it was a
good exercise for me to get my heart
rate going and my blood pressure up and
yeah hope I get an early stroke from all
these threats I'm getting the main
switch is out okay was that the main
switch I just hit okay that's fine so
don't mind my calm demeanor in the
beginning of this game I'm actually sure
that I'm gonna do pretty well because
I've actually built up oh really that's
oh it's gonna be oh this is just gonna
be delightful ain't it okay anyway what
I'm saying is that I've been playing a
lot of these games now so a floaty
controls besides this guy's just a
little flighty for my taste but floating
controls aside I actually think I'm
gonna be okay on this one because I'm
not gonna like overstressed up I'm not
gonna over stress about it I'm not gonna
do anything out of excessive ordinary I
don't even know how to words right now
but not gonna do anything um that's
that's delightful that way that that
worked oh that's lovely this guy is
really slight he so he's actually quite
hard to control because he's he's just a
little bit on ice here for some stupid
reason but whatever we're making it okay
okay alright that's okay you know it's
okay okay that's okay
I build it up so much them I build it up
so much dude I'm doing good and I'm
better at games but then you comes along
something and it's just oh come on I was
why does this guy is way too flippin
floaty
alright you never mind okay heart rank
normal dressed level normal like Brandon
JLA says oh come on
how's that even fair
flipping doing whatever it's just like
it's not my fault guys he always like
overshoots it it goes way farther than
you want him to and then he's like
floats around for Lulu
never mind whatever I'm not even gonna
justify anything about anything cuz if I
can't make it
god damn it what the hell this is pull
flies I'm not trying to lose guys I
really am NOT I know there's a lot of
what the hell I was on that this fall
oh [ __ ] you goddamn it this is this is
completely agra okay this is completely
aggravating because it doesn't do what I
want it to do it's it's god damn it
[ __ ] [ __ ] fine whatever this isn't
even funny rage this is just angry
haha that time he's okay just god damn
finally main switches out
fan-fucking-tastic isn't this fantastic
oh oh I see okay that's right that's
right
I love the music oh come on I was on
that platform I'm this is too early I
just barely started playing the game you
know it's not that this game is art I'm
actually good at these games okay god
damn it stop I [ __ ] didn't do that
it's just so goddamn slighty I swear to
god it's like changing how much he
slides at random it's not consistent
it's just not OK the only way probably
to go there is to oh I see oh oh oh I
didn't I didn't even know that was there
oh okay alright we're fine we're fine as
we got this we got it in it to win it
oh yeah oh
you got it oh whoops never mind good
thing the switches don't reset right
he's so floaty
he's so nevermind all right you know I'm
gonna take a step back and oh not gonna
get to me this time well all right then
celebrate way too early
done why is that done Lisa don't
activate it why what did I miss Oliver
we're done what am I missing
oh god damn it I shook my camera how
long has that been wrong well what am I
missing here what the hell is missing
stop it stop it you see i'm i okay you
guys probably didn't see but i was going
like perfectly horizontal what's going
on
why are you kidding me don't make any
goddamn sense game what did you [ __ ]
bug out on me you better have just
plugged down on me this better not like
oh there's a three level game oh stop
moving stop moving seriously just stop
moving I swear to God
it's all I wanted to do AB okay what the
hell do I gotta get this in one shot I'm
getting better at it because I'm finally
getting adjusted to the controls here
see this is though he's just so sly D
he's so sly D oh he's so sly dude don't
you know yeah I didn't make it good
there we go okay so if I get him all and
by the way I'm just loving this okay
there it goes actually open now oh come
on
okay still open it's still open I'm like
oh come on [ __ ] you oh oh you guys see
why I don't play many rage games cuz I
can't handle it I get very upset when
things don't do what I just I tell them
to do things and then they don't do it
that is my problem with these type of
game they know what they're supposed to
do and yet they choose to do the
opposite it's not my fault it's their
fault
alright I don't even know where I'm
supposed to go here what am i doing
stupid ocean out of nowhere oh why is it
closed
what's wrong again what is wrong no
can't you get off come on
I don't get you game what do you want
from me what do you want from me are you
kidding me
is it really a principle of the game
where I have to go back and loop through
the entire game again is that really
what this is all about they can't
possibly
I do notice that the game music going
backwards now it's going backwards again
does it want me to go back ah you gotta
be go oh come on oh come on get this
game get this game I don't get this game
okay oh that's the main switch oh oh you
gotta be joking me
oh come on oh no go left no no this
isn't even the level come on
I'm not even surprised now
okay okay okay oh what the effing balls
yep yep there we go cha oh why not then
I'm gonna be angry I'm already angry I
just want to get through this next level
and then I'm gonna then I'm gonna stop
because oh okay
yay don't tell me no ding-dong damn main
switches out now
stupid awful music just the worst music
when I'm listening to this - you
couldn't get something pleasant and
happy it just has to be pure ecstatic
punishment it has to be happy - Rima me
up I'm so unhappy I am so unhappy right
now I knew that this was not gonna be a
fun game to play
I just didn't know who's gonna be this
bad like really seriously I'm just I'm
just nope nope I'm not gonna you know
what that main switch can stay out
because I'm gonna stay up here and act
like I won hooray give up a big banner
that says markiplier won yeah okay thank
you guys so much for joining me in this
epic victory I'm so glad that we could
reach the end that and it's amazing I
beat punishment the punishment and now I
never have to play it again so thank you
all so much for watching
[Music]
hey that video
[Applause]